welcome to biscar fixes this is Muhammad
haruni this 2018 Honda Accord
I cut this key for him but we realized
that it doesn't have this aftermarket it
doesn't have
what they call
the remote starter the original one it
have remote starter door lock unlock the
trunk it have extra one
so we need to
I'm gonna take this one back and I will
try to do the other one be sure you have
internet
here it is I gotta go to
to the system
I got a backup from here
accept it
car is running now automatic selection
read it
I'm going to read the VIN number and see
how long it takes
the car is running now but in a certain
time it will ask me
uh to take some key out
but be advised that the 2020
or yeah or 2019 it's kind of slightly
different and you have to follow the
right step out of the other than that
you will damage the body control module
the BCM or the body control module is
built into
the security and everything is one unit
and you need to be careful when you do
that
here we have no problem the only problem
with that you see Vin must be made of 17
characters say okay I don't know why
there is a problem here maybe I'm sure
I'm choosing wrong car see it's a citro
way
that was not what I choose from
beginning but it looked like there's a
problem with the system so I'm going to
delete everything
let me come back here
I start all over this car have a lot of
functions it's very beautiful you have
radar camera lens and a lot of functions
you need to be patient to do it so I'm
going to go to Maxim again I'll start
all over
sometimes I tell you to take those key
out I will do that emo
accept
when you accept it
go by then
let me I don't want the car running
just to reduce the
return this one also
[Music]
okay here give me the key say okay the
information
smart key
push the start
push turn this is push to start
you see here the car
2018 I believe
in Wisconsin
yeah ignition is on
ignition is on you're gonna wait
you see I have two keys
I just want to add a key so it's
different story
everything is good in the car no fault I
just go to other key you see other key
then start be sure you have internet
communicating
turn the ignition switch off
I turn the ignition off
please turn the ignition switch off
place a learning key in the vehicle and
take the other one
so this is a learning key I have to be
here the other one if you don't have
something just put it here under here
see
then close the door
but don't forget and drive the car
please turn the ignition switch on don't
press the foot brake so ignition on
when you say don't press the foot brake
down in the car you don't need the car
to start
okay now maybe sometime
if it's reading anything you're going to
see this building by itself
okay what do you say there two keys
what do you say now
see blue key programming do you want to
program another key yes
so now
place all key out of the vehicle
you have one minute
and 30 seconds to place all the keys so
I'm going to take this one also put it
outside
[Music]
I put it outside here
then I will close the door
say yes
how are you gonna wait
please the key need to be learned you
have one minute and 30 seconds
to do that so the key need to be
programmed this one is that one there
close it and see what's gonna happen
here
example is okay
so now see you see start reading and
they say what success
say okay
do you want to read another one please
turn ignition off do not press the brick
I turn the ignition off
missions on do not press the brake okay
two time
we say our boss keyless immobilizer
indicator turn off
hold on there is a music there I'm gonna
stop the video recording yes
not yet but say yes because the ignition
is on
yes
turn the ignition off
ignition is off
turn it on
[Music]
registration complete
turn the ignition off
you can follow all the steps to close
check all the key
so
good so let me see if I can start it
with this one
and we have to be from outside
let me started for this
I started
everything look okay so you see here I
have three key so I will go out and
push the remote starter because the
other key have a remote start and then
we see what happened
[Music]
this is the second key
and I believe the first one he has is
this very small this one here I'm not
gonna delete it it's still working but
I'm gonna send it back thank you for
watching but stay with us I want to try
the remote star
okay
okay I did that one let me see inside
yes
it worked fine
beautiful
it have a proxy
okay close the door
started
yeah beautiful
now I believe this is
Driver 2
this is driver one you see
but I did not
okay
Driver 2 is different set
I don't know what he have it I'm not
going to change anything but please
subscribe share and like I'll see you in
another video
I'm gonna open this close everything and
see you in another video thank you